all right
processions are common here but these
are not devotees residents of this
Temple Town are chanting against the
government's plan to redevelop this area
and relocate hundreds of people
why does the government even want to
build a new Corridor this will ruin the
town people come here to experience the
history and meet residents like us who
are part of the history what's the point
of the new Corridor if everything is
thrown out
the ancient town of vrindavan in
Northern India is a popular pilgrimage
site for Hindus it's home to the 150
year old Banky bihari temple one of the
largest dedicated to Lord Krishna these
narrow lanes are often crowded last year
a stampede killed two people the
government wants to redevelop five acres
of surrounding area it also plans to
increase the Temple's capacity by five
times
more tourists will come here this will
benefit the local economy we believe the
trade and business will grow it will
also create more jobs so it will be good
for the people of this town
buildings have been marked for
demolition some of these have been
around for decades religious tourism is
big business in India it dominates
domestic travel and generates billions
of dollars every year to capitalize on
this the government has spent millions
of dollars to renovate temples at
religious sites like Varanasi and ujjain
some say the project could destroy the
town's unique history
the streets around leading to the temple
are sacred It is believed Lord Krishna
grew up here the Redevelopment will make
vrindavan like Delhi or Mumbai that's
why I suggested the government shift the
temple to a different area so devotees
get all the facilities
foreign
says it'll compensate people and
relocate businesses residents say the
land has emotional value and the project
will ruin its essence
Northern India
[Applause]